all right this uh you are not going to
believe i would say unless you've been
following politics in the united states
and in which case you won't even find it
surprising
so-called pro-life republicans
self-described pro-life republicans
are now debating whether
women who have abortions should be
killed
really supportive of life aren't they
this is happening in uh texas this is
happening within the republican party in
texas in suburban fort worth house
runoff republicans debate killing women
over abortion the best way to create and
foster a community that supports life
is to kill women who had abortions what
should texas punish abortions by putting
teenage girls and women to death or not
writes yahoo news that's the current
debate of the republican party of texas
where outlawing abortion is no longer a
question of if or when but a question of
whether to kill women for getting one
listen to this they want us to believe
they are pro-life north richland hills
republican david lowe swears his
campaign in the may 24 runoff election
has nothing to do with killing women i'm
not even a fan of the death penalty he
said but then he went on to praise a
house bill that would have made ending a
pregnancy a potential capital crime now
understand that in texas
capital crimes can be punishable by the
death penalty you have an abortion
you're charged with a capital crime
you could be given the death penalty for
that capital crime
do we all agree abortion is murder
he asked the crowd
absolutely
there should be consequences for it
of all the opponents low an afghanistan
war veteran
chose to run against district 91 state
rep stephanie click
click a 35-year nurse has been a low-key
house leader
in texas's one-step at a time effort to
end abortion
texas has reduced
remember legal abortions by about 10
abolishing abortion is important but we
can do that without giving women the
death penalty
the death penalty
they are debating in texas should women
be killed
if
they have an abortion
uh you may remember
um that uh
another texas republican lawmaker is
attempting to make abortion punishable
by the death penalty as reported a few
weeks ago by the texas tribune this
legislation was filed about uh three
weeks ago by state rep brian slaton it
does not include exceptions for rape or
incest it does exempt ectopic
pregnancies that threaten the life of
the woman but this is a bill that would
abolish and criminalize abortions and it
would leave both the women and the
physicians who perform the procedure to
face criminal charges that could carry
the death penalty
they're for life guys
and so if a woman has an abortion
you kill the woman
and you kill the doctor
think about that
now donald trump you may remember kind
of stepped into this the index trump was
pro-choice his whole life trump was
pro-choice 68 years
then he became a republican and ran for
president so of course he had to say i
had an epiphany i had an awakening and
now
i'm against abortion but trump didn't
know the anti-abortion talking point so
when being interviewed by chris matthews
in 2016 trump was asked should there be
a punishment for the women and he said
yes remember this do you believe in
people do you believe in punishment for
abortion yes or no as a principle and
the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form a fine imprisonment for a young
woman who finds herself pregnant have to
be determined wow do you believe now
the next day
trump had to walk that back because the
republicans explained to him no no no
we're against abortion but we don't say
punish the woman that's too far for us
in 2016.
now in texas it's a serious debate
absolutely horrifying stuff
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process
workable helps you cast the widest net
possible by posting your jobs to over
200 of the top job boards with just one
click it helps you evaluate and hire
quickly with modern tools like video
interviews and e-signatures you can
automate some of those repetitive tasks
like scheduling interviews whether
you're hiring for your coffee shop or
your engineering team workable is
exactly what you need to hire the right
people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing just go to
workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below